hi and welcome to the fifth episode of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
co-host from mark hey France sku doing
pretty good pretty good so today we're
gonna be talking with someone from
google yeah frolic manager that is
responsible for developer experience yes
Chris sells the other very excited as
per usual for all our interviews I think
it's going to be an interesting podcast
that's going to sort of look into the
house and wives we make the decisions
that we do it sort of give you some
opportunities to provide feedback so you
can have that wreck things as well so
that's pretty pretty awesome yeah I
think it's gonna be quite interesting to
interview someone that has such a such
an interesting view of the tech industry
in general he's been working so many
cool companies that I'm just his opinion
by itself yeah it's amazing the fact
that he has the power of changing Google
cloud platform vodkas and a Google cloud
platform sorry yeah and the way we use
it even more interesting maybe more
interesting but let's talk about cool
things of the week it's been a really
nice launched recently that i think is
quite quite interesting exciting custom
machine types yeah so got some machines
that machine types what is that so so
far we we've talked during won our first
episodes actually about Google compute
engine and how you can create instances
so basically those are VMs and they have
that we used to have and we still have
them actually list of types of machines
that you can get yeah you can get for
instance the standard one which is what
the name like an n one standard one and
one standard one or standard one and one
we're basically what you're saying is i
want one core and decent amount of
memory not too much not too little and
then we also have so with two cores 4 8
16 up to 32 and then you can choose if
you want the more CPU or more memory but
that was pretty much it so if you wanted
for instance to get a machine that had
32 CPUs but you didn't
one than much memory because you were
doing something that was really really
computation heavy but not that much
memory you didn't really have an option
excited it's kind of a cookie cutter you
know like you got like one size fits all
yeah so more than one size many very
different sizes but not enough yeah so
we basically fixed that glitch so we
have it now when you create a new
instance you actually have in the menu a
way to choose between either the default
types yep or you can create your own
type wow that sounds cool so I can
basically say this is how much CPU I
want this is how much memory I want and
I can custom fit it basically do
whatever my needs up yep exactly so
you're gonna have two sliders one is
going to be for the number of CPUs yep
the other one is going to be for the
size of memory that's it and you choose
whatever you need that sounds really
awesome so and the best part is the
price of that stew that so if you're
gonna use less than where you pay less
yeah that's right so like also if I was
running my own machines may be like
on-prem or something like that and I
want to try and sort of match those in
some way I can be like oh no I can build
my machine spec to match that exactly
yeah yeah and also what I was seeing is
that you can also add do tests on it and
see for instance what it's the minimum
amount of memory that you need trajan
around your your app so you can do that
just start to instance do some tests and
see how it behaves and do it on
different kinds of machines to actually
be sure that the instances that you're
using are the best suited for what you
want to do Wow okay that sounds super
super powerful well we've got a link in
the show notes the blog post that
describes this and obviously the
documentation as well so that sounds
really great so when I get into our
interview with Chris it sounds like it's
gonna be great too okay let's go for
that right so we're here we've
crystelles hi Chris hey guys and you are
a product manager here at google cloud
platform for development experience so
tell us a little bit about what does
that mean sure so what what that means
fundamentally is uh you know well let's
see let me let me say it this way the
this is the old CEO at Microsoft he
would say he would leap up on stage and
say developers developers developers
that's what I do I care deeply about
making sure that developers on the
Google cloud platform have the tools
that they need to be happy and
successful cool so developers developers
developers and tools what are what are
tools for you what are those tools for
developers sure so and and in fact
that's actually kind of an ongoing issue
because pretty much anything that you
can talk to on our platform is a tool
from the api's to the command lines to
the web to the IDE extensions right i
mean you can think of anything as a tool
but fundamentally what what I care
mostly about is making sure that you
have a good way to write your code to
target our platform so that's bring your
own editor that's uh use Eclipse use
Android studio use other IDEs that we
either plug in directly or or work with
partners like JetBrains to make sure
work well that's bringing libraries that
work really well for your particular
language and program against not just
the cloud api's but all of the Google
API s that's being able to test your
code locally make sure it runs the way
you would expect that means being able
to check in your code that means being
able to package your code and deploy it
to our platform and then once it's there
being able to debug problems being able
to look at logs being able to just find
issues and fix them and you know the
cycle goes goes on and on right that
range of tools through the whole set of
developer life cycle for a piece of
software that's that's the set of things
that I that I push on so no much not
much yeah
no it's the couple things couple of
things very another great fit busy
fellow really well it's funny you say
that but I feel pretty busy yeah that's
a surprise that is shocking so so
there's a lot of different things going
on there could you talk a little bit
about what are the last prom the latest
projects you've been working on sure so
very proud in the last few months we
have released kind of language specific
getting started pages for the Google
cloud platform across four languages up
until now we've been really good about
hey you want to learn about a GCS or
datastore cloud sequel or App Engine or
compute engine right kind of from a
product point of view but a lot of
developers kind of consider themselves
by language first right for example to
go to google and they type note how do I
Python how do i write i mean that's
that's how they think of themselves
right I'm a Java developer I'm a ruby
developer and so we weren't doing a very
good job of kind of thinking about the
end and development story from how
developers identify themselves from a
specific language so what we've been
doing is is thinking about the set of
server-side languages that we really
want to push on and then making sure
that developers have a a place to go a
home for that particular language on our
platform and we've launched for those so
far so if you go to cloud.google.com /
nodejs / python / go and / ruby you will
get our first for language starting
pages right entry points into our
platform for those languages nice so so
I'm assuming that included how to use
the API is idiomatically and so what
does it does it does it also include
things like for instance if you're if
you're a Python programmer you may be
using flask on how to use those very
popular libraries on our platform I'm
sorry does um that wasn't surprising I
just had a cough
um so the the answer is for our initial
landing page we've got for all four of
these languages we've got two samples
kind of a hello world what's the minimum
you need to do to bundle up some code in
that language and get it running on our
platform and then we've got a bigger
sample which takes you through a tour of
some of the technologies around our
platform and that's that's what we have
right now and what we've done for each
one of these languages is we've picked a
single framework for example for Ruby we
picked rails of course note is built
right in right that's the frame we use
there um and we've started there over
time we have all kinds of plans to make
sure we cover you know the set of
popular frameworks and a set of popular
tools and you know I'm a rubios well how
do I do this and that thing that I as a
rubios want to do and etc and we have
big plans for expanding that to cover
those and then uh what I'd really love
to hear from your listeners is what they
would like us to do right on you know
what is what does a ruby developer want
us to cover make sure that that we have
instructions on how to do or Python or
etc so that's part of why I'm here to
kind of let folks know that there's
somebody at Google watching their backs
as a developer from all of this set of
languages and if there is something that
you need from from a tooling point of
view I'm the person you can reach out to
and and if I can't get your question
answered or tell you where we are on a
feature then you know I can I can hook
you up with it with who can nice nice so
you mentioned that the four languages
got released on a platform of course now
I have to ask which one's your favorite
actually it's funny you ask that um I
like every developer that's ever picked
up JavaScript have gone through my five
stages of grief is right i started at
denial oh my lord i can't believe
somebody thinks this is a real
programming language and went through
you know anger and bargaining and i went
through the whole thing and I eventually
ended up at acceptance I
for both from a from a client
programming point of view and a server
programming point of view of that set of
languages I would have to say that no it
is my favorite javascript is my favorite
which you have no idea how hard it is
for me to admit that in public hello my
name is Chris cells and I like
JavaScript right that's just that's just
no yeah and this is after I mean to be
clear my my language history i spent
probably 10 years in c 10 years in C++
there was an overlap there of course and
then I gave all of that up for C sharp
and I did c sharp for more than a decade
probably I've done a bunch of C sharp
work in the windows world and then right
before I kind of came over to Google
there was a period of a few years where
I did a bunch of JavaScript work as part
of the windows 8 kind of developer
experience for JavaScript and that's
where I kind of picked it up and at one
point you know I don't know how you guys
are but I i dreamin code sometimes and
and I woke up and I and I had to think
wait what language was that because it
was so natural i didn't know was it
javascript was at c sharp and i knew
that i had been infected with javascript
right that's when I knew the process was
complete I like the idea of talking
about devis cream from an effective fun
of you so you mentioned that that you
tried to get feedback directly from the
person one way of getting that of course
developers going to to us and talking to
you sending emails or just vinegar and
so on guess what what are the other ways
you you find out what kind of features
to add or what kind of documentation to
improve and so on actually that's a
really good question because the
fundamental job of p.m. here at Google
is to is to understand that the customer
needs and in many cases to be the
customer proxy right to bring in
customer requirements and and represent
them to the engineering team and
convince them that this is a good way to
go because none of the engineers work
for me at Google right I mean it's not
like at Microsoft right where
you know the PM got to say jump and the
engineers that how high that's that's
not how it works at Google at all it's
it's very much engineering centric so
it's my job to have data and that data
comes in the form of we do surveys a lot
we do something we call critical user
journeys where we kind of lay out an
end-to-end scenario and help have our
customers with our user experience
researchers work their way through these
scenarios and see how well they do and
we take you know both completion metrics
which is a quantitative and comments
verbatims along the way which is
qualitative so we we lean on that kind
of data a lot and then we lean on um
customer sentiment as well right we we
get to see what people are doing on
Stack Overflow we get to see what people
are doing on Twitter we get to see what
people are doing on our google groups
and all of that kind of forms the basis
of really a ton of data that we've got
that that we use to inform our decisions
about what to build and when to build it
and how important it is and how to focus
our product planning vernis very nice
indeed um you mentioned previously you
talked about sort of IDEs and some
integration there and some partnerships
personally I'm a huge IntelliJ fan I
know that but can you tell us some more
about what's happening in the subway ite
space may be specifically IntelliJ cuz
I'm watching a little bit but I'd love
to hear more I'm sure there's a broader
spectrum people are just what I
specifically want to hear about well
absolutely so we have we shipped at the
beginning of this year an extension to
Android studio called cloud tools for
Android studio although it's bundled
right into Android studio you don't have
to install it separately it just comes
out of the box but essentially what it
enables is you to be a full stack
developer inside of Android studio you
can build your android client you can
build your java based on gcp back end
and we'll even will even build a client
library and as you change your your
back-end will update the client library
and make sure that you know if there's a
change then you know get a pile of error
and you get until our
statement completion and things like
that right so we built that into Android
studio and that's been shipping all of
this year and we found that to be very
popular but as you know or you maybe you
don't the Android studio is in fact a
fork of IntelliJ Community Edition right
the open source and yeah so I figured
you would yes um and so as you might
imagine it's not very far for us to go
from hey let's extend Android studio to
let's extend IntelliJ altogether right
and so in fact we have a github
repository with our the source code of a
cloud tools for IntelliJ that's in the
works if not as full-featured yet as the
cloud tools for Android studio but we're
working on it and we hope to to have
that not only updated in the repository
but to have a binary distribution by the
end of the year so you can actually
deploy from inside of IntelliJ to our
platform at and right now what the the
IntelliJ plug-in does it actually
attaches to cloud debugger so I don't
know if you guys know how cloud to
bugger works but for your listeners the
way the cloud debugger works is you you
you have you're running a java
application for example we're talking
about java now but you have your running
java application on our platform and you
know there's some hard to find bug that
only happens in production right you
can't reproduce it on your development
machine you can't reproduce it
internally these are the ones that kill
you right that that now you're you're
adding you're inserting log printf
statements every other every other line
right to figure out what's going on and
so what we what we do in in the cloud
debugger is you can actually pull up the
source code for the application in
production and set what is the
equivalent of a break point except we
don't actually break we never stop the
process we don't we don't in fact the
user can't even tell we we make sure
that we don't spend more than 10
milliseconds grabbing data and that's
the call stack and that's
the locals so that you can take that
data and dig into it as much as you want
to without harming the user experience
and you can track it down what the
problem is that only happens in
production now that works all great on
the cloud but for that to happen of
course you need to give us your source
code so in a lot of cases we find that
our customers our enterprise customers
and they don't have permission to give
us our source code right there source
code yeah so the nice thing about the
IntelliJ plugin is it worse against the
source code you've got on your local
machine but it never makes it to the
Google cloud right so you can do all of
your debugging for the cloud debugger
inside of IntelliJ without giving us
your source code nice yeah it's very
cool that said that's a that's a really
fun point I didn't actually realize this
Wow okay cool that's very interesting so
I have another question regarding IDs
I'm a go developer like I do go most of
the time and I was pretty excited to
hear that there was four and actually
used to work at Microsoft so you might
know a lot about this so visual studio
Visual Studio code has been open sourced
which is a very interesting very
interesting project and I know that for
instance they added support for go with
the buggers and so on I probably be
announced it like last week something
that is there is there any effort that
we are working like we are working to
have support for Google cloud platform
on vs code and if not is that something
that our community could do or how does
it work so it's interesting so let's
back up and think about with the
technology involved a one piece of
technology is of course you know if we
talk if we think about that end and
developers a set of scenarios that I
that I care about right one of them is
having a set of idiomatic client
libraries right client libraries that
really work well and we already have
there's something like 267 Google api's
we already have nougat libraries to
cover the API so we have a great deal at
very non-trivial amount of usage through
dotnet clients
today using google api sand Google Cloud
api's so that's already one part of the
story you can go to New get you can grab
those libraries you can bring them into
your project today okay we also have you
know the fact that we have the the
compute engine that runs windows server
of course you could imagine deploying
you know your asp.net app to that
Windows Server right it's built right
into Windows Server there's nothing that
stop you from doing that kind of thing
and of course we also have the cloud SDK
that in addition to working on Linux and
Mac of course we have a windows
installer and you can install and use
that today so we already do quite a bit
for the.net developer on windows so
getting back to your your question you
know are we going to dig into vs code
that's actually let me ask that as a
question to the audience because vs code
is interesting because it is essentially
kind of Microsoft's lightweight IDE
lists IDE right it's kind of like
sublime text with debugging and and
built-in support for C sharp right I
mean that's a good way to think about it
it's not at all like the heavyweight
kind of ide that visual studio is on on
Windows and the question is how
important is that integration to our
audience right is is that something that
they think is high on their list do they
want to do kind of C sharp net-based
development on a Mac on Linux or do they
want to fire it up on Windows using the
full visual studio desktop and you know
right now it seems pretty clear that the
usage is visuals to to your desktop but
I'm curious what the adoption will be
and of course based on that then how
quickly we should think about supporting
it yeah that's a very good question that
I cannot really answer no not again like
you were saying like you want to sort of
reach out the audience and we'll
definitely put all your contact details
in the show notes so that you can have
those conversations and we can we can
find those things out because that's
that's important information to have
absolutely and this is part of how I
gather that data to be able to make
product decisions so that sounds really
cool
so now i'm curious whether so I know
there's new and interesting stuff coming
up in the roadmap I'm wondering if
you're able to share anything or at
least teams a little long what's the one
of cool things might be coming shriya
work at Google I feel trouble asking
cool but not come for that yeah go
without confidential things we're gonna
get in trouble for but yeah I'm sure our
listeners would love to see what sort of
coming sure so on the language pages I
already mentioned that we want to do a
lot more right essentially we have a
kind of a minimal getting started we
want to do a lot more there in terms of
content and tools and just be making
that for a place where that programmer
can go and get all the information they
need about our platform or at least
references to to the right resources we
also this these aren't the only
languages we want to do job is coming of
course it's a very important language
for our platform as well as PHP PHP is
also in the pipeline there so those
those are coming down from us you can
also expect i mentioned i mentioned
cloud debugging for java we've got more
languages coming there right so so
that's coming down the pipeline um
trying to think what else i can tell you
it is it turns out right now and you
know probably the last two weeks of my
life and probably the next two weeks has
all been consumed with 2016 planning
right and and google essentially what
that means is we throw everything up in
the air and we think about really what
we want to do what what and what kind of
impact we did we do what kind of did we
move the needle in 2015 how did we move
the needle did we move it as much as we
thought we were gonna and then in in
2016 what do we want to do how do we
take that that set of you know
engineering and p.m. and user experience
resources and figure out what we should
do in the next year to make sure that
our customer gets the absolute most from
the limited set unfortunately limited
set of resources that they that they
possibly can and so now I'm thinking
and there are a lot of possibilities of
things that are coming in 2016 I'm
trying to think if I have any certainty
of any of them I think I'm you think I
might have been in certain already in
terms of what I know is coming which is
debugging and you know the two new
languages and you know deployment
support from IntelliJ and you know so
yeah I've told you probably more than I
should already to be frank good for our
listeners they appreciate that wonderful
okay well as you said you want to get in
content in contact with you do you want
to just give us a little rundown on sort
of ways people can get in contact with
you will obviously put that in the show
notes but I'd like to sort of sort of
have it here as well so that people
people know sure so um first and
foremost my google email see cells
season Charlie esas and sam 'hey LLS
essence am at google com and in fact
it's it's interesting i knew that google
was a good place for me to come because
that alias was available every single
internet email at every single company
I've worked with I was see cells at
right so see sales at microsoft com see
sales at intel.com see sales at google
com right I knew there was a home for me
because that alias was available so that
was a good news i'm also at sea cells on
twitter i'm a big Twitter fan i guess
i'm on facebook but i haven't been to
Facebook's in so long i couldn't
actually tell you maybe they expire you
I don't know um and then my you know my
vanity website i had I've had a blog
since before we called it blogging since
95 actually at cells brothers calm and
it started as a single static web page
which was a bunch of links to windows
developer tools and resources when I
used to teach right and I couldn't
remember all the stuff so I would just
have it on a web page that I could give
to my students and it is now a blog that
I have rewritten 34 times over based on
whatever the current set of technologies
was that I was working with
what language is in you now as of right
now I've actually moved it over to a
hosted service which is it's called blot
and it's awesome because essentially i
add a file to dropbox and press the Save
button and my blog is updated
immediately and it's awesome i'm a huge
fan but but but to answer your question
i had all of that in asp.net and sequel
server and so i wrote like a ton of data
transformation software right to pull it
all out of that and drop it into nice
neat files on my hard drive so that
dropbox could pick it up nice uh is
there any any forum where people can
discuss the kind of features they won
and all of these things is that like
maybe google groups or something like
that that so they could charge so we we
have one of those in the works and we
have some kind of plans for that and so
if people are interested in being on
that group they can drop me a line and i
can make sure that they're in the
initial seed list as part of as we grow
up these language specific sites we want
to have a discussion group where people
can just drop in and and have those
conversations so I I'm maintaining that
list of a kind of initial people to go
into those that new discussion group
we're setting up so people can drop me
all right in there yeah wonderful well
before we wrap up chris is there
anything else you want to mention or
talk about our plug that we haven't
covered so far trying to think um yeah
the the the the well yes there is one
thing which is um where have you guys
been for the last year that i was a
google i only joined in May I'd you know
and it's I've been no other excuse the
mess so yeah and I was busy waiting for
someone to help me with it so when I
when I joined Google whenever I pick up
my new technology like JavaScript when I
picked up JavaScript right
wit and I subscribe to you know I
figured out the right web pages and I
figured out the right RSS feeds and I
figured out the right podcast and i
would spend my free you know minutes
during my commute listening to the
podcast as a way to get up to speed on
whatever the new technology was writen
and honestly listening to the the the
jquery podcast right helped me get over
the hump for JavaScript right and so
when I came to this platform a year ago
right of course I was familiar with
cloud computing in general and had built
distributed software for years and years
but this whole new world of the Google
cloud platform and you know I gave up my
Windows machine and came over to a mac
and you know I had a linux desktop and
where were you guys to help me kind of
make it over that home as I was learning
all that stuff you're you're late but
better late than never I'm very happy to
have you here I've been listening to you
guys on my commute it's been super
useful and so from the community thank
you guys very much I know how hard this
is how much work it is so thank you very
much for this work well thank you for
helping us with these episodes today yes
thank you very much and we'll let you
know any questions that we get from our
listeners will send them directly to you
well thank you Chris that was that was
an awesome interview that was great i
really enjoyed that i learned a lot very
happy to have him finally in this
podcast and very happy that he liked us
so much really like yes yes super happy
about her that's an honor so let's go
for the last part of the episode with
the question of the week the question of
the way today it's related to proven
Aires so we talked about it with in the
episode number two with Brian Dorsey and
one of the things that we discussed was
replica controllers which basically
allows you to say how many instances or
how many replicas of a given but or set
of containers you want to have and the
question that we received was well yeah
that's fine but that's it also auto
scale like willing to create more
instances if I have more traffic or any
other way
so do you know that I do know this this
is a question I get quite regularly
whenever I present about communities so
the really cool thing is is several
weeks ago not too long ago now karuna DS
1.1 was released and one of the great
new features about that is horizontal
pod auto scaling which is like awesome
so it does literally exactly what you
would you would describe you're able to
configure it such that to create and
decrease the number of pods that are
running over the number of containers
they're running the way it works is
through cpu auto scaling okay ma'am so
the number i'm going to make sure i read
this right because it's its mathematical
the cpu utilization is the recent cpu
usage of a pot divided by the sum of cpu
requested by the pods containers Wow
yeah I made sure I read that right so
basically the short gist of it is is you
say things like I want a minimum number
of replicas say like one I want to
maximum number of replicas for like ten
and you say okay the target percentage
is a 50 right so you want to make sure
that the CPU usage stays under that
fifty percent and so if you start going
over it'll start creating colleges to
make sure that cpu usage comes down I
see so you're able to do cool stuff so
that you can like load test your
application make sure that cpu usage is
right you can create up the number of
pods that you need and you can say okay
you know can we handle a million
requests your second or whatever it is
you might actually have to need and it's
yeah it's pretty straightforward and
again mr. Oyama file very standard stuff
is poker buddies that's very interesting
so that's that's something quite new you
say it is it came in the 1.1 release
it's part of the extensions beta type
stuff which is still in beta and
communities but definitely worth playing
with it's going to be a very powerful
new feature I'm very interesting I can
totally see that being governor d is
such an active community not only this
will be included to it but also I'm
hoping we'll have something similar for
memory usage and other metric yeah
there's there's so many options
different communities from over there
but survives it seems this come out very
exciting that's great well alright Fran
Cesc where are you gonna be in the next
few months so you are traveling anywhere
so I'm going to be
home I am actually every year I know I'm
actually going to be in San Francisco
enjoying this beautiful city for 24
changes nice yeah my next trip other
than holidays which will be I'm gonna
spend my holidays somewhere really far
away and really far away from a computer
after that it will go too fast them so
it's these really cool conference like
january in Brussels wonderful well are
you I'm gonna be in Canada I mentioned
it a few times divest in Vancouver after
that I'm not going anywhere for a while
maybe i'll plan a trip back to Australia
for a bit nice what is Vancouver when
were that's the 12th of December that's
gonna be so cold it's gonna be really
good I don't know what I was thinking
yeah well enjoy your time there I will
don't know Reese and talk to you next
week see you next week
you